you know and I wasn't drinking alone I
wasn't you know that I wasn't like
drinking in the dark like uh you know I
was going out and having fun and so
people were kind of touring so it's like
well it's having a blast he's hilarious
you know so it was like it was just a
really great area but so today to have
me end up in the hospital I just had hit
a wall and I had I went on the summer
bender and it bled into the fall now
we're in September and I am in my hotel
in Minneapolis and I start throwing up
pile all over the place which is not
uncommon
are you drunk at this point no I'm what
just woke up and I'm floating up by out
I'm like oh and I feel a pain in my body
and my assistant picks me up to go to
the airport and I'm like hey I think
something's wrong and he goes no you're
just hungover dude and I'm like no no I
know what a hangover is you know what I
mean so we get to the airport I go to
the computer to get my ticket I throw up
in the trash can then I go to the bar
get a drink so my cup string through it
throw that up I'm like [ __ ] now the pain
is like on fire in my body so I got on
the plane throw up in the plane in the
bathroom but I'm sitting at window seat
and I have to puke again the planes
about to Lance you can't get up so I
just like open my carry-on and just do a
little side vomit and my carry-on
okay next to me it's not this laptop and
he just I know he sees me doing it he's
just like so he doesn't look at me so I
just barf and then I get off the plane
and now it's really painful so again I
got his drink through it so I was always
I was always like there's always if you
know this is a drinker with your anxiety
or anything you feel like [ __ ] you
always get to a point and me and my
friends call it the like the magic
cocktail where it's like drink three or
four we're like oh finally where your
nerves and everything finally everything
hits a plateau like oh all right I'm
back and so I couldn't find that I kept
vomiting so I call my agent and I'm like
dude I've got a I've got to go to the
urgent care like this is like bad and
he's like really and he
he's been my agent for 20 years so I go
yeah so this is like a funny part his
life's funny I pull up urgent care by
the Denver Airport and I found one that
was like mile away I'm like okay great
and then I notice that had one star I
was like all right here gets ranked on
stars well first of all I'm like okay
clearly they're not urgent about caring
they have one star I'm like am I gonna
go in and be like yeah I think I drank
too much and they walk out with like a
sex change I'm like no I have a [ __ ]
now no I just said I have a drinking
problem
it's just emergency here so I go to the
urgent Karen and the woman goes oh my
god you need an ambulance and I was like
what and she was like yes they call
paramedics why did she think that she
just I don't know are you green I don't
know what I look like I feel fine I have
no idea I was just like no I'm just
hungover I you know she was like no no
no so the paramedics came and the guy
looks at me he's like whoa he goes
what's your name going through all this
stuff and I answered everything and my
hands are shaking and I go I just have
been drinking a lab of a lot and the guy
goes no I've been on Skid Row for 30
years he's like you need to go to the
[ __ ] ER and I'm like really and he's
like yeah and then the other guy goes
were you and Grandma's Boy and I was
like yeah yeah yeah that's not let's
save that this is more important
important so I go to the ER and I was
there for three weeks this is how bad it
was um are you shooting by the way you
nervous as hell that they're telling you
all these things like what are they
seeing that I'm not seeing other than I
am throwing up when I was in the
ambulance I started to kind of go holy
[ __ ] how did I get myself here you know
what I mean I was like I can't believe
it got to this point and we go to the ER
and they hook me up with morphine and
then I was fine and then my two opening
acts um like found me somehow through my
phone I must have texted them I did when
I landed and then I check something I
was going to the ER and so they found me
and they showed up and then who found
you my opener so the two comedians that
were there I was in Denver for a cake
and
the rest it was just put me on morphine
and then it was flashes and then out
completely lights out for a week and a
half that I came to and then it was just
building just building myself back up
and it was like I mean I've been to I've
been through a lot of things I've been
to the ER and got on IVs and I'm fine
but this was just way different so then
I you know I was released and it was
kind it was a miracle truly a miracle
but truly a miracle that you lived they
the nurse goes you should have died she
goes what you had and what you were your
body was going through she's like I
swear to god you she you shouldn't be
alive it's crazy that you're alive and
it's from alcohol it was a perfect storm
of pancreatitis pneumonia blood bacteria
alcohol poisoning altitude sickness so
five of those things hit my system at
once five and she goes you know you can
die from one of those and all five hit
your system at once and she was like
it's like she goes I can't believe
you're walking out of here she goes
people come in for quadruple bypass
surgeries and they're out in like three
to four days four quadruple bypass heart
surgeries another for four weeks three
weeks